alors on va vous faire comme ça vraiment
que des pommes c'est vrai une fois que
des tendances mais c'était très agréable
il faisait tendance à parler un petit
peu beaucoup comme ça donc on va vous
faire dans on va vous faire un truc très
simple on va vous faire qu'une interview
oui non dans la bouche
en logique la bouche manninger
un fichier des portables qui sonnent
pendant votre spectacle mais si vous
vous retrouvez en paille et or justement
jane par oui ou par non
mais sans faute de français à un effort
l'auriez-vous prête à donner votre vie
pour une cause humanitaire sursis devant
vous dit il ya plus de famine dans le
delta du gange est ce que vous seriez
prête à donner votre avis oui quel jour
est ce que vous croyez que tous les
hommes sont égaux
oui est-ce que vous donnez toujours à
ceux qui font la quête dans la rue non
croyez vous qu'il ya quelque chose après
la mort non est ce que dans sa vie on
peut connaître plusieurs fois le grand
amour
oui si vous trompiez votre jules
actuelle est ce que vous lui diriez non
est ce que vous seriez prête à tout
quitter pour le grand amour
oui existe-t-il un fantasme que vous
n'avez pas encore réalisé ouais
newsletters est-ce que vous accepteriez
de tourner dans un film porno non pour
trois millions de francs les anglais ont
débarqué
ça les gens envoient tout entier de
chênée j'aime pas ma poule à mais selon
laquelle cioni jane non je n'aime pas
trop fou même pour 5 millions 10
millions pour la tchétchénie pour le
monde mais je veux bien mourir pour lui
c'est inné mais je veux pas vendre une
foufoune pour la tchétchénie
fred hassan bayat a quand même sa
manière
est ce que vous vous aimez non est-ce
que vous m'aimez non plus
à l'espace un truc là vous trahir ce
soit particulièrement spontanée comme ça
se trouve c'est un film qui est
débranché salue même temps les blessures
en même temps jamais été aussi accusés
de ma vie ça vient de la faune info là
que d'une réflexion